you're saying it's a step in the right
direction
to at least verify the humanness
of
of a person while maintaining anonymity
but the
so that's one step but the further step
that's maybe
doesn't go all the way because you can
still figure out ways to create multiple
accounts and you can but it's a lot
harder so actually there's a lot of ways
to do this there's a lot of creativity
out there about solving this problem so
if you go to the social media and
political dysfunction google doc that i
created
with chris bale and then you go to
section 11 proposals for improving
social media
so we're collecting there now
some of the ideas for how to do user
authentication
uh and so one is world coin uh there's
one human-id.org
um this is a new organization created by
an nyu stern student who just came into
my office last week uh working with some
other people
and what they do here is they have a
method of identity verification
that
is keyed to your phone so you do have to
have a phone number
and of course you can
buy seven different phone numbers if you
want but it's going to be about 20 or 30
a month so nobody's going to buy a
thousand phones
so yeah you know you can uh you don't
have just one unique id but most people
do and nobody has a thousand so just
there just things like this that would
make an enormous difference so here's
the way that i think about it um imagine
a public square in which the incentives
are to be an [ __ ] that the more you
kick people in the shins and spit on
them and throw things at them the more
people applaud you
okay so that's the public square we have
now
not for most people but as you said just
you know one troll can ruin it for
everybody if there's a thousand of us in
the public square and ten are
incentivized to you know kick us and
throw [ __ ] at us like it's no fun to be
in that public square so right now i
think twitter in particular is making
our public square much worse it's making
our democracy much weaker much more
divided much it's it's bringing us down
imagine if we change the incentives
imagine if the incentive was to be
constructive
and so this is an idea that i've been
kicking around i talked about with reid
hoffman last week and he seemed to think
it's a good idea
and it is
it would be very easy to um rather than
trying to focus on posts what post is
fake or whatever focus on users what
users are incredibly aggressive and so
people just use a lot of abstaining
explanation exclamation points
ai could easily code nastiness or just
aggression hostility
and imagine if every user is rated on a
one to five scale for that
and the default when you open an account
on twitter or facebook the default is
four
you will see everybody who's a four and
below
but you won't even see the people or
fives and they don't get to see you so
they can say what they want free speech
we're not censoring them they can say
what they want um but if but now there's
actually an incentive to not be an
[ __ ] because the more of an [ __ ]
you are the more people block you out
so imagine our country goes in two
directions in one things continue to
deteriorate and we have no way to have a
public square in which we could actually
talk about things and in the other we
actually try to disincentivize being an
[ __ ] and encourage being constructive
what do you think i i well this is
because i'm an ai person
and i've very much ever since i talked
to jack about the health of conversation
i've been looking a lot of the machine
learning models involved
and i believe that the nastiness
classification is a difficult problem
automatically i'm sure it is so i
personally believe
in
uh crowdsource nastiness labeling but in
an objective way where it doesn't become
viral mob cancellation type of dynamics
um but more sort of objectively is is
this a shitty almost out of context
with only local context
is this a shitty thing to say at this
moment because here's the thing
we don't care about individual posts no
no but it's all that matters is the
average the posts make the man they do
but but the point is as long as we're
talking about averages here if one
person has a misclassified post it
doesn't matter right right yeah yeah so
but you need to classify posts in order
to build up the average that's that's
what i mean and so i i really like that
idea what up the high level idea of
incentivizing people
to be less shitty yeah because that's
what we have that incentive in real life
yeah that's right it's actually really
painful to be in a full-time [ __ ] i
think in physical reality that's right
and this off it should be it should be
also a pain to be an [ __ ] on the
internet and there could be different
mechanisms for that i wish ai was there
machine learning models there i did just
yeah but how about how about we have so
one track is we have ai machine learning
models and they render a verdict another
class is crowdsourcing you get and then
and then whenever the two disagree you
have you know staff at twitter or
whatever you know they look at it and
they say what's going on here and that
way you can refine both the ai and you
can refine whatever the algorithms are
for the crowd source and because of
course that can be gamed and people
cannot hey let's all rate this guy as
really aggressive you know so so
you wouldn't want just to rely on one
single track but if you have two tracks
i think you could do it
you